tenemos 3 por x ala o por b por x a la 4
y sabemos que eso es igual a menos 24
por x a la 6 lo que quiero que hagamos
en este vídeo es que le pongas pausa e
intentes averiguar por tu cuenta qué
valores deben de tomar a y b y para
averiguarlo pues podemos simplemente
hacer esta multiplicación porque ello
entonces hacemos esta multiplicación que
es básicamente reescribir lo tenemos por
aquí 3 por equis a la a por b por equis
a la 4 y cuando estamos multiplicando 4
cosas las podemos cambiar de lugar las
podemos reescribir así como 3 por b por
equis a la a por x a la 4 y de hecho si
estás haciendo esto tú solito no tienes
que hacerlo tal cual paso por paso de
esta forma pero espero que así quede muy
claro qué es lo que está pasando pero
bueno esto a que es igual
bueno por aquí tenemos este 3 b tenemos
un 3 b y cuanto es x a la x x a la 4
aquí lo que tengo es la misma base
elevada a exponentes diferentes y lo
estoy multiplicando entonces sabemos por
nuestras propiedades de los exponentes
que esto es igual a x elevado a la a más
4 x a la x x a la 4 es igual a x elevado
a la a más 4 nuclear y nada más sumamos
los exponentes porque tenemos la misma
base y estamos multiplicando así es que
tenemos 3 b por equis a la a más 4 y eso
tiene que ser igual a nuestro lado
derecho esto es igual a menos 24 por x a
la 6
así es que qué podemos hacer ahora pues
podemos darnos cuenta que 3
tiene que ser igual a menos 24 y también
que a más 4 tiene que ser igual a 6 y lo
podemos escribir aquí abajo logueate 3 b
tiene que ser igual a menos 24
seguramente puedes hacer este cálculo en
tu cabeza pero si quieres hacerlo de una
forma más sistemática simplemente
dividimos aquí entre 3
y nos queda que ve es igual a menos 8
por otro lado también sabemos que a
4 tiene que ser igual a 6 y 6 restamos 4
de los dos lados y nos queda que a tiene
que ser igual a 2 y listo ya terminamos
claro que lo podemos checar por aquí lo
podemos reescribir por aquí si a es
igual a 2 entonces aquí tenemos 3 x x al
cuadrado por b que ahora es menos 8 x
menos 8 por x a la 4 x 4 y ahora si 3 x
menos 8 es menos 24 y x al cuadrado por
x a la 4 es igual a x a la 6 y como
estaba diciendo hace rato realmente no
tienes que escribir todo esto pero pues
esto explica bien qué es lo que está
pasando
incluso si haces estos cálculos en tu
cabeza porque hay porque podrías por
ejemplo decir ok 3 x b tiene que ser
igual al menos 24
y para que eso suceda que tendría que
ser igual a menos 8 puedes hacer todo
esto en tu cabeza y después x a la x x a
la 4 tiene que ser igual a x a la 6
y cuando estoy multiplicando cosas con
la misma base los exponentes se sumen
entonces a más 4 tiene que ser igual a 6
por lo que sabemos que la a tiene que
ser igual a 2 si es que tal vez puedes
hacer todos estos cálculos en tu cabeza
súper rápido pero en el fondo lo que
estás haciendo es lo mismo que hicimos
por aquí